you know as you know we have we're
teaching I'm co-teaching it with Howie
Rosen which creates a wonderful
compliment because he has quite
extensive experience in biotech and the
more the engineering and process aspects
I have more experience in catalytic
chemistry a little bit in pharmaceutical
manufacturing more in energy and
petrochemical and so we are we are
really a very interesting complement and
we bring that complement to the to the
course and as he will probably tell you
in another interview that I hope you do
with him that we will be covering some
of the actual mechanical aspects of
identifying opportunities creating
opportunities and and pitching
opportunities and and and the the key
challenges from a from an operational
standpoint to build a company my
interest happens to lie on the
entrepreneur himself and what I had to
live through an experience as I grew our
companies and so I'm talking a little
bit more about leadership and trappin
oriole leadership the difference between
leadership and management how to how to
get into the inner anchor that is
necessary in order to be a good
executive and a good entrepreneur so I
think it'll be a nice complement and for
the students that are at Stanford
locally who are not yet as our other
students already established in their
career what we hope to provide is a
flavor of what it is like to be an
entrepreneur so that when they reach the
the decision points in their in their
journey they have a little more
appreciation of what that particular
pathway embodies and and can can pick
the right right path so we're going to
be covering a range of things it's
really meant to be an introductory
course you could take a whole course in
any one of the topics we're going to
cover but basically we're going to cover
a bit of business basics so we don't
assume that people have any business
training so we'll do a little bit of
that and then we're gonna talk about how
you think about a business and
specifically for a certain idea how you
actually evaluate that and figure out if
it's a good idea and then we'll move on
to once you've gotten comfortable with
okay I've got an idea that I think I
could really build a business about what
are the aspects of building that
business and putting the company
together funding its issues with getting
the right resources both people and
other things and then we'll also cover
the leadership issues involved in
entrepreneurial environments and end up
with a little bit on careers and how all
this fits into decisions you might have
there are two two aspects to this one I
know from my experience with larger
companies both when I was part of them
and when I interacted with them that
there is a an eagerness if you will to
see how activities in the larger
companies can become more
intrapreneurial and that is that's a
serious question okay and I believe the
answer is it can and so I think those in
larger companies that are part of our
program here who are involved in
innovation activities whether they are
discovery new discovery scientific or
engineering or are actually innovation
and marketing and other places I think
some of the concepts we talked about I
think will be interesting for them to at
least appreciate and maybe drawn
that's one piece but the other piece is
that as I said earlier inevitably larger
companies benefit from the innovative
juices of entrepreneurial companies and
to the extent that executives in larger
companies are dealing with entrepreneurs
have to figure out how to work with them
or maybe even convinced them to sell
their their companies or license their
technology it's helpful for them to have
an appreciation of what an
entrepreneurial life is all about and
what we have to do to get through it and
that appreciation will work both ways
because it will make it easier for us as
entrepreneurs to have a sympathetic ear
okay or an empathetic and empathetic
partner in the in the corporation so
their collaboration is a win-win and is
more effective so I would say anybody
who is at a let's say a senior level
maybe executive level or senior
management level that is involved with
these type of activities hopefully will
will benefit from our course yes so
we've we've recurred and I've decided to
specifically focus on engineering and
science based industries so if you want
to develop the next app and sell it for
a lot of money in the next 18 months
this is not the class for you so we're
we're really focusing on industries that
require a significant investment to get
things started take a longer time have a
lot of as I mentioned engineering sort
of science content requires a lot of
different disciplines to actually get
things done typically involves patenting
things or proprietary information and it
can be appropriate for people have BS
degrees or masters or PhDs or perhaps MD
degrees and whether you're thinking of
doing something entrepreneurial in terms
of starting a company or getting
involved in a small company or as
Ricardo mentioned if you're in a larger
company a lot of you may be in a role
where you're interacting with smaller
companies and so appreciating and
understanding their environment and need
can be helpful then also there's lots of
opportunities to be an entrepreneur so
within a larger company to get something
started or maybe have an assignment
where you're starting in your business
exactly exactly and I think that it's a
very interesting question of how do you
inject entrepreneurship into larger
companies within the framework of a
larger company and we how and I will be
talking about that since we both have
have experienced dealing with larger
companies over the last two or three
decades so and and there's an it's a
continuous learning so hopefully
actually I hope that the participants
will actually also contribute to that
dialogue and so we'll all learn
something about that
yeah if there's if there's one thing
it's that being an entrepreneur isn't
any riskier than not being an
entrepreneur so that's my one thing
everyone always thinks it's so risky to
be an entrepreneur but I think it's just
as risky not to be
I think it is the ability to reach out
into many different circumstances and
different people and and in a sense the
virtual learning is becoming not just
unidirectional there is interplay
there's interaction there is visual so I
think the power of that is just getting
outside of our geographic area for me
virtual learning the key thing is the
fact that you can do it whenever you
want wherever you want and you know to
pace you want to so I mentioned that I
have twins were nine years old and they
still don't understand the concept of
broadcast TV to them TV is something
that you watch when you want to you
watch what you want to when you want to
you can stop it in the middle for a
potty break or you know to do an errand
for mom or dad or whatever and to them
that's the way the world should be and
even more so now they'll do that on
their iPads as well as sitting in front
of a you know a TV that's mounted on the
wall so it's really that flexibility and
the ability to access things more easily
without having to actually you know
physically be present and what's four
wonderful about being able to offer a
course that is in a sense long distance
or virtual is that it it allows really
reaching out much beyond just the
geographic zone with the kind of things
that those of us who decided to come and
live here have had the benefit of
you